[Musique]
venu d'angers humaine nouveau numéro d'
interdit d'interdire
l'universalisme républicain les valeurs
républicaines sont devenus des mots qui
fâchent surtout au sein de la gauche ou
ceux qui s'estiment racisées discriminer
ceux qui pensent que le racisme est
systémique qu'il y a une pensée
dominante un privilège blanc sont
considérés comme des identitaires des
racistes des communautaristes ou des
séparatistes alors pour en débattre nous
avons invité louis georges tin président
d'honneur du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires
est également président du cercle de
réflexion république et diversité du
genre je t'avoue publié un livre
d'entretiens avec régis meyran intitulé
les impostures de l'universalisme chez
textuel
c'est vraiment une imposture pour vous
le l'universalisme républicain très
souvent parce que c'est un mot fourre
tout qui est utilisé à toutes les sauces
et qui permet de faire diversion livré
gens se posent des questions sur leur
salaire sur la question de la sécurité
de la santé et l'éducation de leurs
enfants ils ne passent pas leur temps à
se demander si une crise de
l'universalisme danse est une question
mobilisés par les élites françaises pour
faire diversion
henri peña ruiz vous êtes philosophe
vous vous dites volontiers universaliste
marxiste et républicain vous êtes
l'auteur d'un dictionnaire amoureux de
la laïcité et plus récemment de karl
marx penseurs de l'écologie au seuil
c'est une imposture pour vous
l'universalisme républicain ça
m'étonnerait je vais vous répondre
comme vous attendez non ce n'est pas une
imposture
en revanche et sur ce point je rejoint
ce que viennent bien louis georges tin
il y a eu des gens qui se sont prévalus
l'universalisme alors qu'ils exaltait un
particularisme
prenez la critique de claude
lévi-strauss adressait à
l'ethnocentrisme colonialiste il s'en
prend non pas à lui ni
réalisme mais a la prétention qui a une
culture particulière à s'ériger en norme
universelle alors évidemment en tant que
penseur marxiste
moi je n'aime pas qu'on se paye de mou
donc je m'en prends aux caricatures
l'universalisme
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a des
impostures au long de l'universalisme
que l'universalisme lui-même n'existe
pas comme universalisme authentique
marque lui-même d'ailleurs disait la
classe ouvrière est une classe universel
pourquoi parce que elle même après avoir
été exploité n'aspire pas à exploiter
donc là il touchait son de thil
l'authenticité d'un universel qui n'est
pas une dictature
régis meyran vous vous êtes
anthropologue vous êtes à la fois
chercheur éditeurs et journalistes
on vous doit le mythe de l'identité
nationale et les pièges de l'identité
culturelle de livres parus chez berg et
c'est avec vous que louis georges tin
s'entretient dans les impostures de
l'universalisme dont vous rédigez
également la préface et où vous dites
que l'universalisme républicain est un
mythe politique qui apparaît dans les
discours en france en 1989 alors c'est
un mythe ou une imposture pour vous bah
c'est un petit peu les deux c'est alors
on va avoir l'impression que je suis
d'accord avec les deux personnes
précédentes et mais je pense qu'au bout
d'un moment dans le débat on verra que
on est peut-être pas d'accord sur tout
tout le monde en tout cas tous les
quatre mais en effet il ya il ya quelque
chose de l'ordre du mythe politique
il ya aussi quelque chose de l'ordre de
l'imposture et ce qui relie les deux
choses c'est
l'idéologie est en effet s'il ya quelque
chose d'idéologique dans le fait de
mentionner en permanence et comme ça de
marteler ce retour à une sorte d'
universaliste du d'universalisme
républicain qui me semble assez assez
éloignée en fait deux
du vrai universalisme donc de ce point
de vue là c'est une expression qui est
piégé
et je pense qu'il faut se méfier
terriblement et henri pena ruiz a bien
raison de rappeler lévi-strauss puisque
c'est en quelque sorte la réactivation
d'un débat anciens qui avaient déjà lieu
dans des années 50 entre l'universalisme
et le relativisme est effectivement lévi
strauss a dans toute son oeuvre tenté de
faire la jonction entre les deux choses
c'est à dire que il
il était universaliste dans sa
conception de l'esprit humain et de la
et disons de l'interconnexion de toutes
les cultures humaines et par ailleurs il
était relativiste c'est à dire que il
fustigeait l'arrogante civilisation
occidentale il critiquait le
colonialisme et donc il critiquait les
idéologies y compris celle de l'identité
nationale
donc de ce point de vue là
l'universalisme et quelque chose qu'il
faut réformer pour ne pas la laisser à
des idéologues que on voit mon avis
beaucoup trop dans les médias dominants
de nicollin à vous aussi vous êtes fier
un vin vous réfléchissez sur le
socialisme et la république la morale la
justice la liberté et l'universalisme
vous lui avez d'ailleurs consacré un
long article le 19 juillet dernier sur
votre blog est votre dernier livre
s'intitule la force et la morale la
force de la morale comment nous devenons
humain vous l'avez co écrit avec marie
pierre héros jake séparés aux éditions
air et n c'est à dire rouge et noir
l'universalisme ce n'est pas une
imposture pour vous
il ya des imposteurs qui se disent
universaliste mais l'universalisme en
tant que telle n'est pas une imposture
pas plus d'ailleurs qu' aucune doctrine
un tant soit peu étayés je crois que le
problème est pas là depuis très
longtemps on dénonce la manière dont un
certain nombre de deux porte parole
politique utilise qu'elle veut grand mot
parce qu'après tout le socialisme a été
portée par toutes sortes de gens qui
n'étaient absolument pas socialiste mais
qui se sont prévalus du social il n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça encore
et c'est vrai d'à peu près toutes les
théories politiques
donc il est assez facile des dents suite
de dire 'voilà l'imposture socialiste
l'imposture républicaine l'imposture
ceci l'imposture cela on trouve des tas
de poster ce qui me frappe moi dans ce
débat sur l'universalisme que ma
postionne que ma posture c'est qu'au
fond tout le monde se réclame de
l'universalisme
parce que quand on est en cause les
discriminations par exemple pourquoi est
ce que on comptait ces discriminations
parce qu'on pense que tous les hommes
sur terre par leur simple nature d'êtres
humains doivent jouir des mêmes droits
de la même considération de la même
dignité et ce à quoi doit s'adresser
notre sentiment moral c'est un homme en
tant que tel donc voilà et à partir de
ce moment là on peut critiquer tout et
discrimination et parce qu'on a un point
de départ qui est universaliste qui
pensaient qu'il ya une seule nature
humaine qui mérite d'être l'objet de nos
préoccupations morales alors le deuxième
point c'est la question de la république
parce que si c'est la république qui est
la posture parce que c'est peut-être ça
qui est derrière un certain nombre de
critiques contre la posture et
l'imposture république de
l'universalisme républicain bassens et
reprend une autre question parce que
c'est pareil c'est quoi la république
bon moi je sais de travailler depuis un
certain temps sur cette question de la
république je pense qu'une une
définition assez claire de la république
c'est celle que tonnelet il république à
nice tout aujourd'hui la république
c'est de raciste elle qui garantit les
citoyens contre la domination mais tout
est à tendance à s'appeler république et
il ya plusieurs sortes de république
on sait en france qu'il ya au moins deux
républiques depuis 1848 et en 1080 en
février 1848 c'est la république
bourgeoise qui renverse souvenu philippe
et puis en juin 48 c'est les ouvriers
quittent et fit en réclamant la
république sociale et qui se font
d'ailleurs le mitrailler pour ça et je
crois que pour que ce débat soit clair
il s'agit il s'agit de savoir de quelle
république on parle il ya effectivement
un certain nombre de gens qui se disent
républicains dont on peut penser qu'ils
s'excitent à tort de cette qualité quand
ils se réclament des valeurs
républicaines mais ça ne met pas en
cause l'universalisme républicain lui
même en tant que tel en tant que théorie
politique
je vous propose pour démarrer ce débat
de parler de la république française
comme ça on est tous on sait tous de
quoi on parle
la république française elle est très
fière d'avoir aboli l esclavage
le fait que la l'homosexualité a été
dépénalisée depuis la révolution
elle est très fière également que les
femmes l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes soient désormais promu dès
l'école donc on considère dans la
république française qu'il n'y a aucune
raison de se plaindre puisque aucune loi
de discrimine qui que ce soit à partir
sport là nous sommes tous égaux
nous sommes tous frères nous sommes tous
libres et vive la république et
l'universalisme républicain
au fond c'est cette image idyllique que
louis georges tin que vous dénoncez oui
parce que finalement l'universalisme à
la française c'est un oxymore 6 et
universaliste ce n'est pas français si
ces français ce n'est pas universaliste
et surmonte un peu un mot fourre-tout
moi je n'ai rien contre l'universalisme
en soi mais par exemple le mot
catholique catholique au sens grec ça
veut dire universel et les catholiques
se sont définis dès le départ contre le
judaïsme qui était la religion d'un
peuple un peuple élu
il est catholique disait tout le monde
peut devenir catholique et non seulement
tout le monde peut devenir catholique
mais tout le monde doit devenir
catholique et finalement ça aboutit à
bien ce que nous savons et bien
l'évangélisation forcer les conversions
forcées la colonisation et plus le
catholicisme était universel et plus il
est à tyrannique voyez on peut dire la
même chose du libéral
qu'est ce que c'est que le libéralisme
c'est le rêve qui consiste à transformer
la planète terre en un marché ouvert
sans frontières et des ultra libéraux
sont universaliste est-ce qu'on est
obligé d'être catholique est ce qu'on
est obligé d'être ultra libérale pas
forcément donc tout dépend où font de ce
que l'on met dans ce mot si vous me
dites je suis pour le bonheur universel
où la justice universelle
je suis évidemment d'accord mais si vous
vous dites je suis pour un catholicisme
sur la planète entière ou pour un ultra
libéralisme pour la planète entière
là permettez moi d'avoir quelques
réserves donc c'est pour cela que ce mot
fourre tout qui est pratique puisque
tout le monde s'y retrouve ce qu'on peut
tout mettre dedans et un mot qui cache
des disparités évidemment très
importante dans le débat contemporain et
qui cache les vrais enjeux
encore une fois les français ne se lève
pas tous les matins en se disant mon
dieu il ya une crise de l'universel ils
se demandent est ce que vraiment je vais
pouvoir boucler la fin du mois est-ce
que des questions de santé vont pouvoir
être dominés donc ce sont des mots qui
font écran et non pas des mots qui font
le lien social
voilà pourquoi je pense que on n'a pas
grand chose à gagner mais plus on est
membre de l'élite française c'est à dire
sur une base sociale restreinte et plus
on a intérêt à se réclamer d'universel
puisque vous représentez une toute
petite partie de la population française
c'est ça le paradoxe la propension à se
réclamer d'universel augmente à mesure
qu on s'élève dans l'échelle sociale
néanmoins quand on parle des
l'universalisme républicain en france on
parle de la république française et ça
concerne les citoyens français et par
extension tous ceux qui vivent dans ce
pays
et là on est très fier de dire que tout
le monde tous sont égaux ils bénéficient
des mêmes droits et nul n'est
discriminer mis pour sa religion ni pour
sa couleur de peau ni pour cela casse
sociale il incarne il appartient ni pour
ses origines géographiques et être etc
etc
et c'est cet universalisme république
dont un certain nombre de gens
aujourd'hui se prévalent en permanence
pour dire que des gens comme vous par
exemple georges tin avec le livre que
vous venez de publier vous êtes
identitaire communautariste etc
vous voulez pratiquement séparatistes
quoi je me trompe
henri pena ruiz écoutez j'ai le
sentiment que au fond on est on est
d'accord là en ce moment sur l'idée que
quand l'universel est authentique
ils méritent d'être valorisés et ce à
quoi on s'en prend j'ai bien écouté
là encore louis georges tin il ya
beaucoup de choses dans son lit moi qui
m'ont touché je tiens à le dire très
sincèrement par la véracité de ce qu'il
dit j'ai l'impression qu'on s'en prend à
une caricature d'universel par exemple
effectivement frédéric là vous venez
d'évoquer avec beaucoup d'ironie et vous
avez sans doute raison
la mystification qui consiste à dire que
tous les français sont égaux tous les
habitants de la france sont égaux et on
sait très bien il a encore sur une
critique très forte de marx c'est que on
peut avoir une démocratie formelle qui
reconnaît les droits formels alors qu'en
réalité les conditions socio économiques
qui pourraient rendre crédibles ces
droits ne sont pas réunies prenons un
exemple simple partant de fort chômage
quelle est la liberté d'un chômeur en
fin de droit de ne pas signer le contrat
de travail qu'on lui propose est-ce
qu'il a le pouvoir de discuter telles
clauses concernant l'emploi du temps
qu'on lui impose non
donc évidemment il serre les dents il
il a la rage parce que il est présenté
comme un agent totalement libre alors
que la cruauté de la nécessité une
famille à nourrir et ses loyers à payer
fait qu' il ne peut pas refuser
contrat de travail en droit il le
pourrait enfin il ne le peut pas mais
est-ce que c'est l'universalisme qui en
cause non c'est le différentialisme la
caricature puis on a parlé du
séparatisme
monsieur battre on parlait du
séparatisme islamistes mais il aurait
bien fait aussi de parler du séparatisme
des exils fiscaux ou du séparatisme de
ceux qui ont des revenus faramineux
jamais l'écart entre les revenus du
travail et les revenus du capital n'a
été aussi grand et là évidemment c'est
une caricature d'universalisme alors les
gens de l'élite économico sociale qui
ose dire qu'il y à l'universalisme en
france nous trompent
6 il faut s'en prendre à une caricature
idéologique qui sert à justifier le
pouvoir des dominants mais il faut par
ailleurs veiller à ne pas s'en prendre à
l'idée d'universalisme quand nelson
mandela prend le pouvoir
après 27 ans dans les geôles l'afrique
du sud il dit
dans la nouvelle afrique du sud y aura
de la place pour tout le monde y avait
pas de place pour les noirs dans
l'apartheid mais y aura de la place pour
les blancs dans la nouvelle afrique du
sud s'assainit versalis mme il l'a
combattu l'apartheid qui était un odieux
différentialisme mais lorsqu'il a été
président il a imposé le fait de traiter
à égalité les blancs et les noirs et ça
c'est un universalisme qui est un
universalisme tout à fait extraordinaire
qui peut servir d'exemple
alors on voit bien puisque vous êtes
tous entre entre jambe gauche et chant
bien vous allez vous entendre sur la
lutte des classes sur les questions
sociales
là où ça va être plus difficile c'est
dès l'instant on va parler de races ise
de d'état de racisme d'état d'un terreau
sexualité
là normalement vous devriez plus tout à
fait être d'accord et
régis meyran vous pouvez peut-être
ouvrir le bal oui alors absolument c'est
certainement là où il y aura des
divergences de points de vue henri pena
ruiz rappelle que marx était
universaliste et c'est évident marx
avait la théorie de l'homme total c'est
à dire qu'il fallait que les individus
se réalise pleinement dans leur vie dans
le travail
c'était un idéal à la fois eu une sorte
d'humanisme rénové est en tout cas
c'était un universalisme marx aussi
s'interrogeait le 1er mars le jeune marx
des manuscrits de 2008 sont que 44
s'intéresser à la question écologique
comme l'a montré jadid butler même si je
suis pas forcément toujours fan de james
butler mais là se sont livrés très bien
sûr sur marx et la question écologique
mais par contre marx était un homme de
son temps il s'est pas intéressée à la
question raciale il s'est intéressé à la
question des femmes liées aux questions
et joe alors c'est pas une reprise mais
voilà ni aux questions de genre
absolument et alors oui peut-être enfin
ça peut être discutée mais en tout cas
je c'était une façon d'introduire le
débat en disons que c'est pas la faute
de marcq bien sûr mais il se trouve
qu'en france
ce que je regrette moi personnellement
c'est que la gauche se soient dessaisis
des questions de genre des questions de
de couleur et de race au point que le
mot de race est devenu tabou
non pas que je le défends moi je pense
que la race n'existe pas au sens
biologique et j'ai travaillé là dessus
en plus j'ai travaillé sur les théories
des anthropologues et des ratios log du
xviiie siècle au xxème siècle donc c'est
une escroquerie
là pour le coup ce scientifique par
contre la race existe comme
représentation sociale et elle a des
effets sociaux terrible parce que du
moment où vous êtes
regardez comme étant vu comme
appartenant à une telle ou telle race on
vous attribue un certain nombre de
caractères donc ces questions là qui
sont en fait mis en avant par les
nouveaux féministe par les militants
lgbt par les nouveaux anti raciste et
bien son amende à mon sens beaucoup trop
critiquer mêmes diaboliser y compris par
la gauche qu'ils auraient que plus
républicaine et ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment dommage parce que bien sûr que
dans en fait ce sont des galaxies c'est
à dire que ce soit des nouveaux
féministes les nouveaux anti racistes
vous avez des positions d'ailleurs
théorie qui peuvent être parfois
incompatibles qui sont très complexes il
ya tout
il ya tout un champ est ce que ce que je
regrette c'est que la majeure partie de
danse à une grande partie en tout cas de
la gauche diabolise cc nouveau mouvement
en refusant de considérer que ce sont
des questions essentielles à traiter
justement pour améliorer cet c'est de la
république et pour améliorer notre
conception de venir ces 10 secondes et
nicolas vous ai souvent l'ue critiquant
l'inde ce que vous appelez l'indigénisme
par exemple vous n'êtes pas le seul
d'ailleurs tout ce plan non la gauche
n'a pas laissé tomber la question des
femmes la question du genre et c'est la
gauche à commencer par laisser tomber la
question sociale c'est un tout il faut
partir lorsque le fond de la question et
que depuis 1900 allez on va donner une
date 1983 mais aussi un peu pour marquer
les esprits depuis 1983
la gauche s'est orienté vers une
politique d'adaptation et même
d'anticipation du libéralisme et que la
question sociale ne l'intéressent plus
et même cette partie de la gauche qui
s'est tourné vers le libéralisme a
théorisé l'abandon de la question
sociale
vous avez un fameux rapport de thé rhône
de terra nova il ya quelques années qui
expliquait que le parti socialiste
devait délaissé les classes populaires
parce que ces points-là qui trouvera des
électeurs et qu'il devait se tourner
vers les nouveaux mouvements
c'est à dire les mouvements des femmes
les mouvements des banlieues etc etc
c'est à dire que c'est le mouvement
politique en france lui-même qui a
commencé par opposer les revendications
qui peuvent être légitimes de tel ou tel
groupe et les revendications sociales
il faut quand même pas oublier ça à ce
que je tombe ni la gauche ne pense qu'à
la lutte de classe mais pour du tout la
grosse n'y pense pas du tout à la lutte
de classes et six autres fiches la lutte
de classe comme de là
car entre les ouvriers peuvent rester où
ils sont et d'ailleurs tout le monde
s'en contrefichent parce que l'on est en
train de discuter de choses très
importantes très intéressant mais le
sort de dizaines de millions de nos
compatriotes eux tout le monde s'en
fiche
comment ils vivent comment ils finissent
les mois ça c'est quand même le vrai
problème
moi je pense qu'il y a plus de rapports
entre un ouvrier blanc et un ouvrier
noir puisqu'il faut mettre des couleurs
partout maintenant on est dans la crau
mocratie 1 que entre un ouvrier noir et
ça fait trop noir parce qu'il ya des
noirs qui appartiennent à la bourgeoisie
et des noirs qui sont multimillionnaires
qui viennent nous donner des leçons
d'antiracisme tremblant privilégiées ça
commence à bien faire voilà et tout ça
participe d'une tentative général qui
est d'en finir avec la lutte de classes
tentative qui d'ailleurs que rich man en
philosophie et dans le grand monde
idéologique a commencé il ya déjà
longtemps dans des années 70 80
je pense par exemple pourquoi la french
theory a eu autant de succès c'est parce
que justement la french theory était
radicalement anti marxiste et c'est pour
ça qu'elle est qu'elle a eu du succès et
tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui sont très
largement des mouvements idéologiques
qui sont mis d'eux ça donc du
refoulement de la lutte de classe de ce
primate la lutte de classe et je crois
que là-dessus effectivement risque
d'erreur des désaccords entre nous ça
c'est clair possible parce que moi je
continue de penser que c'est là
l'essentiel
il ya des discriminations raciales c'est
évident mais ces discriminations elles
ont autant frapper les blancs et les
noirs
est ce que vous voulez qu'on parle de la
condition des travailleurs en france des
travailleurs
alors qu'il ya quelques il ya un siècle
les gamins de 5 ans qui poussait les
berlines dans les mines
il s'était pas discriminer eux ils
étaient ni noir ni homosexuel ni quoi
que ce soit c'était des bons blancs et
héros et tout mais poussait les berlines
à 5 ans dans les mines mais c'est de ça
dont il parlait et est-ce qu'on pourrait
parler de la situation des gens qui
bossent dans les usines des situations
des gens qui sont licenciés qu'ils
soient noirs ou blancs qu'ils soient
homosexuels ou hétérosexuels
c'est peut-être quand même ça le vrai
problème le reste j'ai envie de dire
c'est quand même des problèmes de riches
et c'est le petit monde parisien moi je
vous fais à fond de ma province là c'est
notre petit monde parisien qui discutent
de ces petits problèmes entre
voit effectivement grave l'usure je sais
ni sarsgaard paul les français s'y
intéressent pas tout se gâte la raison
bien sûr ici intéressement parce qu'on
n'en a rien à faire parce que le vrai
problème il est aujourd'hui la situation
sociale et puis avec ce qui nous est
tombé dessus et avec l'opération
qu'ovide je vous garantis que demain
matin ça est encore une autre paire de
manches
parce que la pauvreté a explosé dans ce
pays elle va continuer d'exploser
et c'est peut-être de sa qui serait bon
de parler aujourd'hui plutôt que de
s'interroger sur son nombril
alors qu'il ya des discriminations par
exemple vis-à-vis des femmes c'est
évident 1
mais le mouvement syndical avait
toujours lutté pour le principe à
travail égal salaire égal
et c'est sur le torse terrana que la
situation des femmes a progressé
qu'ils aient eu des discriminations à
l'égard de contrôler les gens de couleur
comme on dit ce qu'on emploie aussi le
vocabulaire américain maintenant c'est
aussi évident mais le mouvement ouvrier
a été le principal facteur antiraciste
dandin dans l'histoire de notre pays
je me souviens d'un d'un film américain
dianne déjà une quarantaine d'années
s'appelait harlan county usa qui
racontait une grève dans les mines chez
des mineurs et à la sortie on
interrogeait de deux mineurs en leur
demandant s'il ya des problèmes de race
entre eux a été répondu c'est quand on
sort de la mine on est tous noirs et ça
la question ce qui est permet
l'universalisme réels effectifs concrets
pour l'universalisme abstrait des
bavards et bien c'est précisément la
mobilisation du monde du travail c'est à
mobile pour des luttes de classe voilà
je suis un artiste via la vieille matin
je vous prie de m'en excuser mais je
crois que c'est le fond de la question
je pense que louis georges tin des tas
de choses à répondre et qu'il aura pas
le temps parce qu'on a une pause à faire
on va faire la pause et je vous donnerai
la parole juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on prend ce débat avec louis georges tin
et régis meyran qui viennent de publier
les impostures de l'universalisme chez
textuel avec henri peña ruiz qui est
l'auteur d'un célèbre dictionnaire
amoureux de la laïcité et de nicollin
qui lui a publié la force de la morale
la parole est à vous je lui georges tin
mais on voit bien ce qui sépare vos
revendications d'une bonne partie des
intellectuels en france il ya ceux comme
elisabeth badinter qui disent que de
parler de leurs assises et ou de
privilèges blanc c'est du racisme
et puis il ya ceux comme de nicolas qui
disent qu'en gros c'est s'occuper de
choses pas très importante les choses
vraiment importantes c'est
l'exploitation d'une classe par l'autre
que le patron soit noir ou l'ouvrier
soit soit blanc ça change rien c'est
toujours des rapports de domination
entre classes alors votre réponse moi ce
que je dirais c'est que pour ce qui est
de la gauche et d'une partie de la
droite
ils ont laissé tomber et la question de
la classe et la question de la race
entre guillemets au fond d'ailleurs
c'est pour cela que la gauche française
est dans cet état et même la droite
traditionnelle
également ils ont laissé tomber tout le
monde et je crois que toutes ces
questions sont importantes c'est à dire
dans les années 70 certains marxiste
disait aux féministes
oui vous devez convergé vers le combat
ouvrier et des féministes disais mais
pourquoi est ce que les ouvriers ne
pourrait pas convergé vers le combat
féministe après tout il ya autant de
faim dans le pays que d'ouvriers sans
doute plus donc il n'y a pas de priorité
à faire l'ouvrier hommes il y
certainement exploiter
l'ouvrière femme l'est davantage et ce
n'est pas parce qu'on est ouvrier qu'on
peut être encore plus discriminée si
effectivement on est femme harcelée
sexuellement exploités économiquement
donc il ne faudrait pas faire une
hiérarchie en design ya le vrai combat
qui serait économique et les autres
combats qui serait non pas des questions
sociales mais des questions de société
je n'ai jamais compris d'ailleurs
la différence entre ces deux concepts
donc l'ouvrière qui est violée par son
patron est exploité par le même patron
je n'ai pas envie de dire qu'il ya un
vrai problème un faux problème ce sont
des questions massive et qui sont
finalement écartées ou négliger aussi
bien par les partis traditionnels que
les nouveaux partis donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment peut inclure tout le
monde est au fond et c'est là peut-être
qu'il y à véritable universalisme à
trouver peut-être même à créer la
question des discriminations qui est
aussi importante que la question
économique au sens marxiste du terme
elle est aussi universel car tout le
monde est discriminante
par exemple la question de l'âge et bien
tout le monde a été jeune
tout le monde est appelé à vieillir et
même quand on est entre deux âges par
exemple 30 ou 40 ans vous pouvez être
discriminés parce que vous êtes trop
vieux pour avoir une promotion alors
vous avez le talent ou jugés trop jeunes
paraît sur l'apparence et bien quelle
que soit votre apparence il ya des gens
qui vont trouver que vous avez une tête
qui ne leur vient pas au style
vestimentaire qui ne leur convient pas
etc etc
donc la question des discriminations
n'est pas la question des minorités
car on est toujours la minorité de
quelqu'un d'autre en fait et c'est pour
cela que c'est une question tout aussi
universel que la question économique
il ne faut donc pas les opposer il faut
au contraire les réunir henri peña ruiz
oui alors d'abord je voudrais pas
laisser dire que marx ne s'est jamais
occupé de la question de la race
n'oubliez pas que dans une
recommandation après la création de la
première association internationale des
travailleurs
1864 il s'adresse aux ouvriers
américains et leur dit un aspect
essentiel de notre lutte
c'est de ne pas laisser continuer
l'esclavagé peau noire tant qu'existera
les esclavages soupe au noir vous serez
vous même si vous êtes sous peau blanche
destinée à être solidaire et on sait que
marx a fait l'éloge dithyrambique
d'abraham lincoln pour avoir mené à bien
la guerre contre les esclavagistes donc
effectivement et marque sur la question
des femmes aussi disait son ami en guest
également que dans toute société on
mesure le degré de civilisation d'une
société au sort qu'elle réserve aux plus
démunis or là où je rejoins aussi un peu
oui georges tin c'est qu' il peut y
avoir des cas de sueur détermination de
l'exploitation
c'est vrai que la femme peut être
exploité en tant que femme dans une
société patriarcale et la laïcité joue
un rôle très important en émancipant la
loi civile de la loi religieuse parce
que souvent la loi religieuse à
sacraliser le patriarcat c'est le crabe
ailleurs des trois monothéismes le
judaïsme le christianisme et l'islam ont
sacralisé le patriarcat et une femme
prolétaires elle était finalement
souvent doublement des exploités en tant
que pro laideur et en tant que femme
donc effectivement là on retrouve la
nécessaire liaison de toutes les
émancipations l'émancipation des noirs
pour marx était essentielle une tâche
essentielle à accomplir pour
l'association internationale des
travailleurs et je crois
qu'effectivement tout à l'heure on s'en
prenait un petit peu globalement ou
abstraitement à à toute la gauche qui
aurait délaissé la question des
discriminations
je crois que c'est un peu injuste c'est
injuste par sa généralité
c'est une critique trop générales je
sais que effectivement à gauche la
question des discriminations a été
abordé la question du plafond du plafond
de verre c'est une expression qui a
utilisé notamment yamina benguigui
cinéaste qui explique que souvent des
personnes parce qu'elles appartiennent à
une ethnie des thermes
né peuvent rencontrer une sorte de
plafond invisible dans la promotion au
sein de l'entreprise et la persistance
de la différence de salaire entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est encore un
problème réel
de même le fait que quelqu'un parce
qu'il s'appelle mohamed ou autres
n'obtient pas l'entretien d'embauché
c'est ce sont des faits réels et il faut
s'en prendre à ces faits réels et je
crois que il n'ya pas il n'y a pas à
reposer une émancipation à une autre
c'est vrai et je suis en ce sens
d'accord sur ce point que l'émancipation
socio économique et la lutte contre le
capitalisme est très importante mais
elle doit être aussi un point de
réunions de la lutte pour tout les
émancipations et je crois qu'il ne faut
pas être injuste en dix ans la gauche
globalement aurait délaissé la question
sociale au profit de la question
sociétale je crois que ces deux
questions sont très importantes
en revanche ce qui s'est passé et ça
vous l'avons vécu douloureusement à
gauche c'est que sous prétexte qu'on
allait s'occuper de la question
sociétale
on avait laissé la question sociale et
ce n'est pas une bonne chose
donc effectivement je crois que nous
avons à écarter les malentendus voir
quel est le noyau de sens qui peut faire
notre accord sur ce qu'est un
authentique universalisme évidemment
l'universalisme a été caricaturé on a
baptisé universel ce qui ne l'était pas
c'est clair que dans l'idéologie de la
colonisation
effectivement on a fait ce genre de
manipulations idéologiques dénonçons le
mais restons toujours fidèle à cette
idée que l'homme est homme comme le
disait tout à l'heure de nicollin ce qui
est universel
c'est la propriété d'un être humain de
réfléchir d'être
mo sapiens de résister à ce qu'ils
oppriment si quelque chose nous
empêchent de respirer j'essaie de
respirer un grand coup
spartacus ne pouvais pas respirer
librement quand ils étaient esclaves
il a défini l'esclave comme un homme
libre raturé et l'universel n'existe
nulle part s'est dit n'est pas
géographiquement situés l'universel
c'est ce mouvement de l'être humain qui
cherche à s'affranchir de toutes les
aliénations essayé nous prenons cette
idée qu'on trouve d'ailleurs par exemple
c'est valter benyamine quand il parle de
la tradition des opprimés nous pouvons
peut-être nous mettre d'accord sur ce
qu'est un authentique universel en
général les gens de gauche se met assez
souvent d'accord quand il parle du passé
quand on parle du présent fait plus
délicat et on pourrait le résumer d'une
manière femmes d'ailleurs quand les
associations antiracistes s'appelait la
licra le mrap ou sos racisme toute la
gauche était d'accord et les supporters
depuis que les associations antiracistes
s'appelle le cran la brigade anti
négrophobie la voix des rroms les
indigènes de la république il ya
beaucoup plus de problèmes pour une
raison simple c'est qu'avant les sacs
safiatou aventis racistes dénoncés les
racistes qui étaient des gens méchants
qui n'est même pas l'écrivain mais pas
les autres à cause de leur couleur de
peau
aujourd'hui les nouvelles associations
antiracistes dénoncent un état qu'il
considère comme assiste un racisme donc
systémique un racisme au fonds dont nous
les blancs profite aurions tous quand
bien même nous ne serions pas raciste
nous serions quand même des privilégiés
et nous en plus nous n'en serions même
pas conscient puisqu'il y a une pensée
blanche une pensée des dominants qui
fait que nous trouvons absolument normal
d'être blanc des privilégiés et de
croire encore que nous sommes les plus
nombreux
le divorce est ce qu'il n'est pas là à
partir du début des années 2000 quand
tout à coup les racistes ce ne sont plus
les méchants racistes d'extrême droite
comme on avait la tendance allait à les
caricaturer autrefois fabrice mayrand
ben je crois que vous avez entièrement
raison
frédéric en effet c'est là la grande
différence entre les anciens
antiracistes et les nouveaux anti
racisme et pourtant il me semble que
alors vois je peux par exemple en parler
en tant que blanc je pense que la notion
de privilège blanc par exemple elle est
tout à fait justifié et et quand on est
quand on est blanc ou comme quand on est
hétéro sommes dans un monde masculine au
centre et dans un monde patriarcal
il faut faire un effort de penser
supplémentaires pour arriver à se mettre
dans la peau des gens qui subissent des
discriminations
parce que eh bien il est plus facile
d'être blanc pour trouver un appartement
pour trouver un travail
on le sait je veux dire les il ya de
nombreuses enquêtes qui le montre tout
simplement
donc tout ça devrait être en fait de
l'ordre de l'évidence
donc c'est ça qui me surprend c'est que
on diabolise cette question du prix
neiges blanc alors que finalement elle
est assez banal c'est finalement un
concept de la sociologie de la même
manière l'autre problème soit disant que
soulèvent les universaliste républicain
c'est la question de l'intersection
qualité mais alors c'est vraiment un peu
barbare qui a été inventé par une
professeure de droit américaines noir
et en fait ça dit une chose assez simple
c'est que et bien vous pouvez avoir une
combinaison des discriminations qui
combine des problèmes de classes des
problèmes d'identification à la race
disons et des problèmes de genre 10 sous
cette forme là c'est d'une banalité
totale la limite je veux dire il n'y a
pas de quoi sauter au plafond
donc le problème c'est que vous avez
comme je le disais tout à fait en début
d'émission il ya un certain nombre
d'idéologues y compris d'ailleurs à
gauche enfin c est ce qu en général ils
sont quand même très à droite ou à
l'extrême droite des gens qui partent au
combat contre ces nouveaux anti racisme
qui mélange absolument tout qui font
semblant de ne pas comprendre le concept
d' intersectionnelle it et qui ne font
semblant de ne pas comprendre le
privilège blanc et je pense que c'est là
qu'est le problème et je pense aussi
qu'on les voit beaucoup trop dans les
médias alors je prends un exemple à
gauche puisque là on est entre personnes
de gauche c'est le printemps républicain
que je trouve pour ma part totalement
catastrophique alors un exemple parmi
d'autres c'est le professeur de sciences
politiques laurent bouvet avec sa
théorie de la sécurité culturelle alors
le mais enfin il est finalement comme
d'autres gens du printemps républicain
c'est quelqu'un qui est systématiquement
dans le rejet de ces nouveaux anti
racisme dans le rejet de l'islam de ti
qui l'assimilent beaucoup trop
rapidement et systématiquement à
l'islamisme il est dans le rejet de des
féminismes qu'ils veulent qu'ils
voudraient être las le séparatisme etc
et puis don qui théorisent la sécurité
culturelle il dit que bon finalement les
petits blancs seraient se sentiraient
menacés dans leur culture par l'afflux
massif de migrants ce qui est d'ailleurs
et pas une réalité puisqu'en fait il ya
très peu de migrants qui viennent en
france et puis beaucoup en repartent
mais donc ce petit blanc se sentirait
menacé il sera en insécurité culturel
c'est pour ça qu'ils quitteraient les
banlieues pour aller dans le périurbain
et c'est pour ça qu'ils voteraient front
national et donc ça je trouve ça très
grave et est en fait c'est ça que ça
cache ce tout ce débat sur
l'universalisme républicain c'est la
critique caricaturale des nouveaux anti
racisme
et nouveau féminisme des militants pour
les droits homosexuels et au détriment
il ya à dire à l'opposé de ça ils vont
défendre une vision complètement
idéalisée de la république et donc ça
c'est un vrai problème et donc je ne
pense pas pour finir je pense pas que
ces nouveaux mouvements contribuer à
faire disparaître la question sociale je
ne pense pas puisque c'est aussi du
social c'est simplement une autre forme
de social est en fait il faut tenir
compte de tous évidemment qu'il ya des
ouvriers qui sont sur le carreau
il ya des supers prolétaires il ya des
supers pauvres il ya des sdf
il ya le un capitalisme qui écrase le
pays
il faut lutter contre ça mais c'est pas
une raison pour ne pas traiter non plus
des autres formes de domination qui sont
aussi terrible mais on leur reproche pas
seulement de faire disparaître social on
leur reproche de s'attaquer carrément à
la république en disant qu'on est noirs
en disant qu'on est femme racisées
homosexuels tout ce qu'on peut faire
comme combinaison parce que vous pouvez
mettre une femme prolétaires noir
lesbiennes et musulmane alors elle est
là la totale
mais à partir du moment où elles se
revendiqueraient de tout cela on lui
dirait qu'elle s'attaque à la république
puisque la république ne veut voir
qu'une seule tête d'une certaine manière
ça n'est pas le cas de nicolas
non pas du tout la réplique ne peut
avoir qu'une seule tête si on est
républicain comme je pense qu'on devrait
l'être à la démence c'est pas forcément
la république tels que on l'a pencher
les républicains ou d'autres gens du
même genre et la république son point de
départ c'est la protection contre la
domination et la protection de la
domination ça veut dire que personne ne
doit être dominé quelles que soient les
raisons qu'on qu'on invoque un bon
république a ni style est résolument
hostile
évidemment à la domination des hommes
sur les femmes comme à la d'immunisation
des blancs sur les noirs etc
je dire ça c'est celle a baissé de la
pensée république à nice telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui est telle que je la
défends est donc la question des à mon
avis n'est pas du tout là le problème
je revenir sur cette question de
discrimination
le problème c'est l'utilisation
absolument incontrôlée et sans aucune
discipline de penser du mot
discrimination loup georges tin est
interdite tout le monde est discriminée
moi je suis un déjà passablement vieux
je suis cochet j'ai déjà été discriminés
pour ces deux choses là est ce que je
vais faire un mouvement
intersectionnelle des vieux cons chez
discriminer avec je ne sais qui c'est
pas la question je veux dire on en train
de tout mélanger
le problème n'est pas véritablement là
des screaming discriminés sur le
problème c'est celui de l'égalité
moi je suis pas contre l'un pour la
non-discrimination su pour l'égalité
c'est pas exactement la même chose
l'égalité ça suppose l'égalité des
conditions sociales ou du moins une
relative égalité des conditions sociales
et en particulier ça suppose la fin de
cette domination qui est exercée dans
les rapports de production dans les
rapports sociaux
tout à l'heure on me donnait l'exemple
d'une femme qui est doublement exploiter
effectivement elle est doublement
exploité mais les doublements ex
possible pourquoi parce qu'elle est déjà
exploité et parce que son mari est
exploité et sinon ne seraient pas
exploité du tout elle serait la femme
d'un riche et l'aurait je ne sais
combien de
deux personnes pour faire les tâches
ménagères à sa place et ne l'effraie pas
et elle elle pourrait mener une vie
oisive tranquille et donc la question
c'était une question de classe toujours
la surexploitation de certaines couches
est une question de classe
de la même façon les travailleurs
immigrés sont surexploités souvent et
parce que d'ailleurs on les utilise pour
ça parce que ça permet d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre plus malléable parce que ça a
permis de faire baisser le coût du
travail
soit dit en passant c'est une des
variables les plus importants des 20
dernières années c'était la baisse du
cours du coût du travail et la baisse de
la part relative des travailleurs dans
le revenu national
il sait absolument considérable ça ça
n'inquiète pas grand monde 1 pendant
qu'on s'occupe de discrimination on
oublie ça parce qu'il y en a qui savent
très bien ce discriminer eux et ceux
discriminer positivement c'est les
riches ils s'en sont mis plein les
poches et encore récemment on a des
statistiques qui ont prouvé que les 0,1
pour cent plus riches ont explosé leurs
revenus
les milliardaires français au cours des
dernières années ont multiplié leurs
richesses par 4,5
etc etc et c'est ça qui entraîne tous
les autres mécanismes d'exploitation
s'est pas autre chose
un homosexuel il n'est pas opprimer
parce qu'il est homosexuel
il est opprimé parce qu'il est pris dans
une mécanique qui est celle de la delà
de l'exploitation et parce que c'est un
homosexuel riche effet absolument ce
qu'il veut enfin voir arrêter de
raconter des bêtises faut regarder la
vie telle qu'elle existe vraiment si
vous avez les moyens à personne viendra
vous embêter c'est quand vous n'avez pas
les moyens quand vous êtes quand vous
êtes un pauvre quand vous êtes dans une
banlieue on pourrait parler par exemple
de du sort qui est réservé aux hommes
sexuelle d'un certain nombre de banlieue
dans pour elle ça ça pourrait assez
intéressant de voir que l'intersexualité
ça fonctionne pas toujours comme on
penserait un bon voilà pourrait revenir
sur ces questions là donc je pense que
le problème c'est pas la discrimination
en elle-même le problème c'est la
question de l'égalité
moi je veux pas que préférait avoir je
sais pas moi des quotas de patron noir
moi je suis pour la suppression du
patronat c'est tout à fait autre chose
parce que je suis un vieux marxiste
encore une fois je suis pas pour qu'il
ya une femme qui soit patronne ça m'est
complètement égal c'est une affaire
entre eux ça les regarde je suis pour
qui et l'égalité des hommes et des
femmes sur le plan du travail l'égalité
des salaires
mécanique des constructions de travail
mais en l'occurrence eu pour une égalité
un peu particulière je pense qu'il faut
une égalité qui protège aussi
spécifiquement les femmes puisque
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et avant que les savants fous n'est
trouvé le moyen c'est les femmes qui
portent les enfants dont elles ont
besoin de protection spécifique
donc il faut peut-être en leur faveur
une espèce de sueur égalité donc une
discrimination si vous voulez appeler sa
discrimination mais c'est ça la question
fondamentale sa question de l'égalité
l'égalité personne ne doit être traité
différemment la loi est égale pour tous
et ce taux ça dont il vous parle il faut
partir
la discrimination à l'école par exemple
c'est pas une veste discrimination et d
fondé tout le monde le sait sur les
inégalités sociales
monsieur louis georges tin lui il a eu
la chance de faire henri iv de rentrer à
normale sup s'en félicite d'être agrégé
des professeurs de faculté il n'a pas
été discriminée à mon avis et or tous
les cas ils étaient beaucoup moins
discriminée que beaucoup samedi plantes
qui n'ont jamais pu mettre les pieds
dans une deux au lycée corot qu'on
oriente et très tôt sur la voie
professionnelle
il faut pour quand même penser à ces
gens là moi par exemple été discriminés
parce que comme je t'ai pas un est venu
d entre eux vident et où j'ai pas fait
henri iv voilà j'ai passé mon agrégation
en travaillant tout seul dans mon coin
bon oui alors je dors je suis
discriminer bronche pas discriminer j'ai
je venais la vie qui me plaisait kiné
j'en suis très content donc la quête
l'égalité l'égalité la question
d'égalité c'est une question sociale sa
question des rapports de classe c'est
pas moi j'entends bien on me dit il ya
les rapports de classe mais ça ça
s'appelle de la dénégation terme fera du
bien quand je commence par ya bien s'y
met ça veut dire non ce que tu viens de
dire en premier ne compte pas et ça je
n'ai cessé de l'entendre ce soir il ya
des rapports de classe mais non ça veut
dire ya les rapports de classe et le
reste en découle des rapports de classe
bon mélange de cas je vous interromps
parce qu'il ne reste pas beaucoup de
temps jeu là on est au coeur du débat
parce que vous le dites aussi dans votre
livre il ya déni de la diff
errance ou du moins des différences dans
cette république universaliste qui est
la nôtre est hélas on nie tout on y
touche avec ce que vient de dire de
nicollin puisque en gros pour lui vous
êtes un privilégié par les études que
vous a fait fait ou on va dire que kylie
ann m bape est un privilégié par les
revenus considérables qui le tire du
football et que en gros si vous nous
venez nous expliquer que du fait que
vous êtes noir vous n'avez pas les mêmes
chances que les blancs vous êtes
discriminés faut quand même pas exagérer
quoi ce que je dirai d'abord c'est que
souvent ceux qui parlent du nid fort
d'universalisme veulent prenez-le unis
formalisme
en gros ils veulent dire l'universel
c'est moi je suis un homme blanc
bourgeois parisien et donc les normes
qui sont les miennes doivent être des
normes universelles
en réalité le monde c'est l'ensemble des
personnes toutes différentes toutes
égales normalement et je pense que ces
associations dans des domaines très
divers
il est très important qu'elle puisse
travailler ainsi je ne suis pas certain
qu'on aurait pu aujourd'hui enfin
prendre la mesure de l'antisémitisme et
de la shoah
s'il n'y avait pas des associations
juives faisant un travail spécifique est
tout aussi universaliste sur la question
du droit des femmes
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'associations
féministes je ne sais pas si on aurait
pu avancer de la même façon sur
l'égalité entre homosexuels et
hétérosexuels il fallait des
associations lgbt
sans quoi on serait toujours
probablement dans la même discrimination
donc je crois que il faut absolument de
cette diversité vous savez c'est comme
la maladie
moi quand j'ai mal au ventre je vois mon
généraliste mais s'il me dit monsieur ça
c'est pas un problème de ventre c'est un
problème en fait de rein et bien je suis
content qu'il y ait un écologue qui a
spécialistes et donc de la
discrimination
il ya des gens qui seront sur des
problématiques générales comme la ligue
des droits de l'homme
mais pour travailler sur la question des
femmes peut-être que la ligue des droits
de l'homme n'est pas la mieux placée il
fallait des associations féministes et
bien la discrimination c'est comme un
mal social il faut des généralistes
il faut des spécialistes et bien voilà
ce qui se passe est aujourd'hui
effectivement ces mots qui fâchent on en
a parlé il cache en réalité beaucoup de
choses très diverses mais lorsque les
nouveaux anti racistes dont je suis
puisque c'est le terme que nous
opposée et bien ce que nous disons c'est
que nous voulons l'égalité donc je ne
vois pas évidemment d'opposition par
exemple on dit bien sûr une pensée
magique en france liberté égalité
fraternité et on a l'impression que
lorsqu'on a dit ça tout est réglé moi je
dis simplement d'après une étude qui a
été faite par matignon
je n'invente rien et bien l'écart
salarial en france entre noirs et blancs
il est de 30 % est entre nos mains blanc
et une femme noire une femme arabe à
travail égal
l'écart est de 49 % c'est-à-dire quand
un homme blanc touche 100 % 100 euros si
vous voulez et bien la femme arabe
touche 51 euros mais ça personne ne le
dit à tradition sectional it et jeudi à
travail égal à travailler des choses
égales par ailleurs
oui absolument et ça soit le rapport je
vous invite à le voir c'est franc
stratégie un organisme sous l'égide de
matignon qui l'a publié
ça on n'en parle pas ça veut dire qu'en
gros il voir les arabes sont traités à
égalité jusqu'au 14 septembre et à
partir du 14 septembre
c'est le jour à partir duquel comment ce
qu'on appelle le bénéfice blanc alors
c'est ça c'est intéressant il faut le
dire et c'est ça la discrimination mais
je ne dis pas encore une fois qu'il ya
une hiérarchie c'est à dire que il y a à
la fois la question sociale c'est-à-dire
socio économique et les questions
sociétales qui sont aussi sociale là
aussi c'est un mot qui n'a pas de sens
je lui dis les femmes qui sont moins
payées que les hommes et c'est une
question sociale autant que sociétal et
je pense que moi je suis un homme
eh bien je serai le premier à
reconnaître que forcément je bénéficie
du sexisme
je ne suis pas sexiste et moi-même en
tout cas j'essaie de ne pas l'être mais
que je le veuille ou non et bien
l'argent dont je bénéficie c'est de
l'argent qui n'est pas allé aux femmes
sssa l'intersexualité monsieur vous avez
dit je n'ai pas été discriminés parce
que j'étais à normale sup mais j'y tiens
normale sup mais j'ai aussi été
discriminés y compris à normale sup mais
j'ai pu réussir malgré les
discriminations donc voilà mais en tant
que normalien un professeur d'université
je suis 2001 en tant que bourgeois
aujourd'hui je suis dominant mais ça ne
m'empêche pas évidemment d'être
solidaire de tous ces culs sion
prolétaires de ceux qui sont fans de ce
que tous ceux qui sont discriminés
interrogé par exemple georges tâche
obligé de vous interrompre parce que
l'émission se termine dans une minute il
ya le discours du président de la
république et je voudrais donner la
parole à henri peña ruiz la dernière
minute elle et avoue henri pena ruiz
oui je voudrais pas abuser d'un
privilège mais il ya quelque chose qui
me choque dans les nouveaux mouvements
antiracistes
c'est de dire que la laïcité est un
racisme d'état
ça c'est absolument scandaleux ou yat-il
on évoque effectivement les normes
vestimentaires mais les normes
vestimentaires ne vise pas une catégorie
particulière de la population
j'étais dans la commission stasi qui a
fait la loi de 2004 et qu'on a
recommandé la neutralité vestimentaire
on ne visait pas que l'islam on ne
visait pas que le web
contrairement à ce que des journalistes
parfaitement malhonnête ont prétendu on
a cité d'ailleurs dans le rapport
la kippa lacroix charismatique et le
voile est ce que c'est de la
discrimination non c'est tout les six
d'appartenance qui doivent être dans
certaines circonstances n'ont pas tout
le temps évidemment parce que là aussi
il faut le rappeler qu'ils doivent être
effectivement discret et qui ne doivent
pas être arboré je vous interrompre
malheureusement henri pena-ruiz parce
que le discours du président de la
république tant attendu où il va nous
vraisemblablement nous re confiné en
tout cas à paris le soir commence je
vous remercie d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivi on et
vos prochains numéros
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]